minimum wage work can make you a
millionaire but not the way people think
for example if you're flipping burgers
right now that is not directly going to
make you a millionaire for sure but the
thing is is that you learn skills when
you're flipping burgers that allow you
to do the next thing you learn how to
show up on time you learn how to follow
instructions you learn how to
communicate these are all skills that
you're actually going to get paid to
learn and those are skills that you will
need on your path to becoming a
millionaire a lot of people think that
because they are working right now and
the vehicle they're in is not making
them as much money as they want that
they think that it's the wrong vehicle
to be in and that's not necessarily true
because if you don't have that step you
can't move on you can't pass go on the
board